nous sommes en 2018 le vendredi 13
Juillet Fernand Lopez me tabasse ça
gifle je vais vous la mimer c'est un
parpin de Forin c'est ce qu'on appelle
un parpin dans dans notre jargon ça part
bien d'en bas là et il me la met il
frappe avec cette partie première touche
je suis KO ce sont les pleurs de notre
fille qui me réveill moi il y a une
petite fille pendant des années elle
disait maman elle fait dodo papa il fait
bobo tête à maman ces mots là ils sont
ancrés ici bien sûr j'avais
honte j'ai pris j'ai ça m'a pris
beaucoup de temps avant d'en parler pour
la première fois Cécile jnelli sort du
silence et raconte devant la caméra de
brut les violences qu'elle a subi de la
part de Fernand
Lopez j'ai mis 5 ans à me reconstruire
Fernand Lopez est un coach de MMA il
entraîne entre autres Jordan zebo Cécile
jnelli est nutritionniste du sport elle
travaille entre autres avec Cédric doub
et c'est à l'occasion du combat entre
Cédric dumb et Jordane zebo le 30
septembre que l'affaire a fait la une
suite à cette déclaration comme je l'ai
dit moi c'est pas Jordan que je combat
j'ai dit il faut changer l'affiche c'est
Fernand Lopez que je combat et voilà
pourquoi j'ai tenu à ce que les gens
sachent à ce moment-là c'est ça que je
mets chos c'est ce sont les violences
faites aux femmes c'est ça que je mets
ch c'est celui qui frappait sa femme
quand j'étais dans sa salle et voilà la
raison pour laquelle j'ai quitté C
Cécile jnelli raconte ce qu'elle a vécu
quelques années aaravant
nous sommes en 2018 le vendredi 13
Juillet Fernand Lopez me
tabasse il y avait une petite embrouille
une petite tension familiale et pour la
première fois en 5 ans de couple Jose
lui dire un gros mot et là que sa propre
femme lui dit je t'emmerde il n'a pas
supporté et moi sa gifle je vais vous la
mimer c'est un parpin de Forin c'est ce
qu'on appelle un parpin dans dans notre
jargon ça part bien d'en bas là et et et
il me la met il frappe avec cette partie
au karaté donc karaté 4 aussi de base on
appelle ça tencho c'est une partie très
très très forte très
puissante première touche je suis cas ce
sont les pleurs de notre fille qui me
réveille ma petite fille de 1 an et demi
elle est là je me réveille parce que
j'ai j'entends une voix enfin je sais
pas si c'est l'instinct maternel ou quoi
et j'en prends plein la tête hélas
malgré meses mes années de de
pratiquante en arts martiaux je fais
partie des gens qui ont un réflexe qui
est de figer je n'ai mis aucune aucune
je me suis pas défendu je me suis laissé
faire la seule chose que je disais
c'était non arrête s'il te plaît il y a
Gabrielle notre petite ça l'a pas arrêté
est-ce que sur l'instant est-ce que vous
avez eu peur de mourir vous êtes dit
voilà avec tous les coups que je suis en
de prendre est-ce que là je vais pas en
sortir vivante pas ce jour-là je v vous
parler d'autres fait de violence ceux
dont Cédric a été témoin ce jour-là non
je réalise pas en fait j'ai j'ai même
pas le temps de penser à ça la seule
chose à laquelle je pense c'est ma fille
que j'entends pleurer il y a une petite
fille c'est ça qui est terrible pour moi
parce qu'à chaque fois on dit que c'est
moi la victime moi il y a une petite
fille pendant des années elle disait
maman elle fait dodo papa il fait bobo
tête à maman ces mots là ils sont ancrés
ici vous dites être revenu dans cette
relation après les premiers coups du 13
juillet 2018 qu'est-ce qu'on se dit en
tant que femme qui a vécu des violences
est-ce qu'on ose dire à ses proches qui
sont au courant des violences je me suis
remise avec avec cet homme violent
elle m'imuse cette question parce que
j'ai eu bien sûr j'avais
honte j'ai pris j'ai ça m'a pris
beaucoup de temps avant d'en parler je
me rappelle Cédric et moi on a pu parler
pendant long longtemps et j'osais pas
lui dire je savais ce qu'il allait me
dire et quand il l'a pris il m'a dit
Cécile non mais c'est ton choix pour ces
faits de violence à l'encontre de Cécile
jornielli Fernand Lopez a été condamné
en septembre 2019 par le tribunal
correctionnel de bobini à 4 mois de
prison avec surcis dans un article du
Parisien daté du 1er octobre Fernand
Lopez a réagi aux déclarations de Cédric
dumb et est revenu sur ses violences
mon geste est inexcusable un être humain
un homme ne lève pas sa main sur une
femme c'est injustifiable de dire quoi
que ce soit je suis allé au commissariat
et j'ai reconnu avoir giflé ma femme il
n'y a pas plus lourd de condamnation que
celle que je me suis infligé à moi-même
celle d'avoir été un homme qui a été
violent avec sa femme on se sent comme
une merde c'est pour ces propos que
Cécile jnielli réagit aujourd'hui après
avoir répondu dans un premier temps sur
Instagram le lendemain de cette
interview on ne prend pas 4 mois pour
une gifle moi c'est ce qui m'importe
c'est qu'hier ce sont les violences
faites contre les femmes qui ont pris un
chaos la question aujourd'hui c'est de
se dire qu'est-ce que vous attendez de
cette prise de parole justement pourquoi
prendre la parole
aujourd'hui lavez mon
nom c'est important laver le nom de mon
père mon ex-conjoint parle d'un fait de
violence une gifle c'est ce qui m'a mis
hors de moi une gifle il y a eu des
faits de violence reporté à la police
euh avant ce vendredi 13 juillet donc
c'est pour ça je je souris avec beaucoup
d'amertume quand je lis cet article du
Parisien qui parle d'une baffe d'une
gifle pardon que il regrette ça toute sa
vie il y en a eu avant il y en a eu
après parce que ce que vous dit
excusez-moi votre ex-conjoint en effet
dans cet article c'est que vous aussi
avez assainé des coups à lui et à sa
grande fille qui est d'un précédente
union exactement exactement alors une
fois effectivement je lui ai mis parce
que bon moi j'ai était j'ai découvert
beaucoup de de liaisons de tromperies
j'ai des cornes tellement hautes que et
je me suis pas respecté pendant des
années he vraiment à accepté toutes ces
tromperies c'est mon choix c'est voilà
c'est un je reviens pas sur
ça mais donc je une fois je découvre une
anème tromperie et sur son tort je lui
dis mais pourquoi pourquoi mais de façon
pathétique je lui tape ici voilà la
violence que j'ai eu avec lui et
vis-à-vis de sa fille une fois c'est
vrai je lui ai mis une fessée quand
était toute petite j'aurais pas eu à le
faire c'était pas mon enfant je me
trouve pas d'excuses mais elle mettait
en danger
la l'enfant que j'ai eu avec lui qui
avait 3 mois je bon j'avais pas à faire
ça l'histoire entre Cécile jnelli et
Fernand Lopez prend fin en 2019 ce
jour-là Cécile journelli est au
téléphone avec son ami Cédric dumbé
cette amitié je la cache au père de ma
fille ça reste au stade de l'AM AMTI et
en gros on est en on arrive en février
2019 février
2019 où le père de ma fille me dit qu'il
me quitte et moi il faut savoir que je
encore une fois je me suis pas respecté
moi je le supplier tout le temps de
rester et là pour la première fois je
lui dis jacqu es je n'ai rien dit
d'autre à part jacqu es comment on
s'organise pour la petite et là il
devient fou je sais même pas ce qu'il a
dit il a parlé pendant 25 30 minutes à
gesticulé dans tous les sens mais je
sens sa violence qui monte moi il faut
savoir que quelques mois avant je me
fais taper sur la
gueule donc la j'écoute pas ce qu'il dit
j'écoute juste une voix dans ma tête qui
dit Cécile dis rien Cécile dis rien dis
rien dis rien donc je je
fais rien d'autre et dans dans je sais
pas si c'est ça qui le rend fou je sais
pas parce que d'habitude j'ai toujours
tendance j'avais toujours tendance à
dire à être dans le dialogue à essayer
de le convaincre et là rien du tout et
vient ouf en fait donc il y a pas eu
d'attaque à ce moment-là de la soirée si
ce n'est de une tentative de
m'impressionner à venir mettre son front
coller son front sur le mien comme on
fait dans les les les combat de boxe en
fait et et moi c'est impressionnant
enfin je je j'ai peur je le monte pas
mais j'ai peur il sort de la pièce et là
donc c'est là où on parle des 1h du
matin et tout le monde dit mais
qu'est-ce qu'elle faisait avec 1hure du
matin à 1h du matin avec Cédric parce
que le père de ma fille nous a prêté une
relation
il nous a prêté une relation pour que si
un jour les fait de violence sorent qu'
oui mais en même temps c'est pour laver
son honneur elle l'a fait coocu
comprenez et donc auprès d'un certain
public ça peut justifi c'est pas ça qui
s'est passé ce qui se passe c'est qu'à 1
heure du matin j'ai peur j'ai besoin
d'une voix qui me réconforte parce que
je sais que il va être avec moi dans la
maison il va dormir à côté dans le lit
j'ai j'ai peur j'ai besoin d'une voix
qui me rassure
je vais sur le balcon pour pour
téléphoner
endroit où il ne venait jamais jamais
jamais et là je téléphone avec céric je
lu explique ce qui vient de se passer et
il est en train de me dire Cécile pars
de la maison
par j'ai pas eu le temps le père de ma
fille est venu sur la terrasse commence
à me dire à qui tu parles je lui dis
j'ai pas à te le dire j'ai pas à te le
dire tu viens de me dire que nous ne
sommes plus ensemble ok donc n'ai plus à
te dire quoi que ce soit il insiste il
insiste là je commence je je je rvis la
scène c'est ouf je mets mon bras en
distance physiquement en disant s'il te
plaît arrête parce qu'il se
rapprochait je disais arrête tu me fais
peur mais c'est d qu'il entend tout au
téléphone et à un moment donné il entend
mon cri pourquoi parce que ce bras il me
le prend justement il me fait une clé de
bras et il m'arrache le téléphone donc
qu'est-ce que je fais je court dans le
salon où il y a un fix pour appeler les
flics il me poursuit il démonte
l'étagère en parce que bon bref là où il
y avait le téléphone il explose le fix
par terre j'ai pas de téléphone portable
j'ai pas de fix
j'ai j'ai aucun moyen là j'ai eu peur
pour ma vie Cédric connaissait pas mon
adresse mais il savait que sa sœur était
venue souvent chez moi donc il appelle
sa sœur elle lui donne mon adresse et il
envoie les flics chez moi c'est comme ça
que il me sauve la vie Fernand Lopez n'a
pas été condamné pour ses faits de
violence de 2019 et n'a à ce jour
effectué aucune déclaration à ce sujet
sur les réseaux sociaux depuis quelques
jours une vidéo circule montrant Cécile
journelli avoué avoir trahi l'homme
qu'elle aimait elle a tenu à réagir à
cette vidéo la poogé de mon emprise
c'est que j'étais capable de tourner des
vidéos dans lequel j'ai un Chima
corporel je suis comme ça enfin on voit
que je suis toute quelle femme va va
tourner une vidéo en disant j'ai trahi
mon conjoint et en fait là cette vidéo
elle ressort parce qu'il sait que j'ai
parlé de quoi il s'agit c'est une vidéo
dans laquelle je dis j'ai trahi l'homme
que j'aime j'ai trahi l'homme que
j'aimais avec un de ses amis trahison
dans le sens loyauté en tant que femme
en tant que femme je n'avais pas à être
amie avec quelqu'un qu'il n'appréciait
pas voilà donc vous le pensez encore
aujourd'hui mais oui un peu oui
vous trouvez qu'il y a une omerta Cécile
dans le monde des sports de combat une
sorte de silence tout le monde sait des
choses mais personne ne parle dans cet
univers je ne trouve pas qu'il y a une
omerta il y a une omerta il y a une
omerta après que tous ils se soi sentis
tenus en
otage parce que ils savent que s'il
parlent ben en fait c'est la fin de leur
carrière aussi on est encore une fois
face à quelqu'un de puissant sur les
médias sur les
relations sportives politiques qui qui
qui s qui qui se vente de ça donc oui il
y a une omerta et je suis venue la
briser